It's freaking gnarly, dude.
It's as gnarly as I could
have imagined it being.
This is a lot of fun.
Just really nervous about
how fast I'm going to be
actually flying off the lip.
With drop kayaking,
when you're really pushing
yourself is when
you feel more alive,
but it's really dangerous.
Waterfall running is not
something that everybody
likes to engage with.
You come in with speed,
and then you immediately
go to a vertical freefall.
You are going from 45 miles
an hour to a dead stop.
It feels like being
whiplashed in a car crash.
We take hits.
Hitting your face with your
paddle, breaking your nose,
which is why we sometimes
throw the paddles.
The benefit of
throwing your paddle,
it creates less
chances of hitting
yourself with the paddle.
With a hydraulic, you
have this curtain of water
that's hitting
the pool, and it's
pulling you down underwater.
If you are in a hydraulic,
you can also play dead,
and then the water will pull
you down and pop you downstream.
It's kinda sketchy out there.
If you go too far right,
it has a really bad spot
where it kind of folds back
in and you would probably
just break your boat and die.
The Rio Santo Domingo has
this super steep section that
had never been done before as a
complete top-to-bottom descent.
I get it.
They're crazy-looking
rapids, man.
Before running a rapid, you
always visualize the line.
How are you going to
enter the current?
Where are your reference points,
a rock or a breaking wave?
And where do you want
to be on that lip?
I feel like we need a solid
safety team down there, dude.
And the amount of people
that we have right now,
I'm not sure if it's enough.
On trips like this, you have
to trust that your partners are
going to be able
to potentially save
your life because in
big drop kayaking,
you can plan every move,
you can scout every line,
but until you're in the
water, you don't know
exactly what's going to happen.
The most important thing
for me is not getting hurt.
I don't want that for my family.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[BABY COOING]
[VOCALIZING]
How are you, buddy?
ALI CASAS: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Hey, what you guys reading?
When I met Gerd,
I started kayaking.
He's been a good
teacher, and we've been
kayaking together ever since.
You got the keys?
ALI CASAS: Kayaking
gives you more
mental strength because
you're about to run
something that scares you.
I trust him a lot,
and I know that he
doesn't do stupid things.
But I worry all the time.
I just don't tell him.
Nice!
Let's go.
You ready?
We have two tiny
persons at home
that they are waiting for
him, and you always think
that something bad can happen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]